[Music]
five
thousand years ago kondok was a melting
pot of cultures
wealth power and magic
yet most of us had nothing except for
the chains
around our necks conduct needed a hero
instead they got me i did what needed to
be done
and they imprisoned me for it
now five thousand years later
i'm free and i give you my word
no one will ever stop me again
i have a knack for destroying bullies
but there are some who think i need help
hawkman
dr fate
and their new recruits
cyclone
and adam smasher they call themselves
the justice society
an organization that believes in
fighting for truth
and justice well i'm going to teach them
that the only beliefs i fight for are
mine
welcome to truth justice and the black
adam way
[Music]
so as you guys can see we are
cooking up something pretty badass and
and certainly a lot of fun that we are
all
excited about to deliver to you guys um
and i can't wait to show you more
you know i always thought that it might
be cool to hang out with superman
that would be cool right i mean we're
kind of similar in terms of our powers
our strengths our speeds because look at
the end of the day you never know
black adam and superman could become
friends
or they won't
who knows maybe we'll see but before i
go
i want you guys to help me out with
something it's something that's pretty
important
i need you guys to help me get a message
out to uh
to some of the other ones some of the
other dc superheroes
let's let flash shazam
aquaman wonder woman
batman and superman
let's let them know something things
will never be the same
because the hierarchy of power in the dc
universe
is about to change
welcome back everyone do you smell what
the rock is cooking so this is going to
be my new black adam trailer video there
were also a bunch of big casting
announcements they just made in the past
week about the movie so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we'll do a new amazon
giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know when you want
to see them cross
black adam over with the justice league
because that's basically what the rock
is telling us at the end of that trailer
i'll just go through the footage shot by
shot talk about the easter eggs and then
i'll talk about the casting
announcements when we get to those
characters
so number five the trailer footage
obviously just shows you what his
costume is gonna look like during the
actual movie
and even though he has the same powers
as the shazamly the footage gives you a
good idea for how they'll tune them to
look a little bit more hardcore than
what you saw in the shazam movie
but the trailer itself is him basically
narrating his origin story and them
telling you what the plot of the black
adam movie is going to be they're
basically giving you the entire plot
right here without giving away too many
big spoilers
that intro scene where the camera is
winding through where he's saying i've
waited a long time for this
these ancient hallways are basically
inside the tomb where he was trapped for
thousands of years by the wizard shazam
he was trapped by the wizard shazam you
actually see him narrate that part of
the trailer after he released the seven
deadly sins
that scene itself was referencing the
other black adam scene that we saw
during the shazam movie at the beginning
where he's explaining to billy
who black adam was without saying in so
many words they're changing his
backstory a little from the comics he's
starting out as a slave in conduct
forced to help build their monuments
which itself sort of borrows from real
world history a lot of the great
pyramids and egyptian monuments from
thousands of years ago were built using
slave labor number four most of you
probably picked up on the easter eggs
during his voiceover backstory there
but when he talks about having problems
with bullies and it looks like the
slavers are beating him he talks about
how
people needed a hero but they got him
instead that's them doing the exact same
origin story moment
as billy batson got in the shazam movie
with a very dark twist
billy sees freddy getting picked on by
bullies he attacks them because he hates
bullies then the wizard shazam detects
that he has great potential to be the
hero that he needs
and grants him his powers it's the exact
same thing that's happening to black
adam in the trailer here
slavers bullying everyone in conduct
then black adam beats them within an
inch of their life
way more hardcore than billy against
those bullies in the shazam movie
obviously the council of wizards which
are all still alive during this period
in history
see his potential to be the hero that
they need in this area
grant him the powers of shazam but the
darkness within him is just too
great he's too hardcore when he says he
did what needed to be done
then they imprisoned me for it he's
talking about releasing the seven deadly
sins
based on the other footage in the
trailer he's saying that he saw the
problems in conduct is so great and
systemic
that the only way to fix the area was to
cleanse it with a biblical level event
the seven deadly sins and obviously the
council of wizards is like
hell no that is way worse you're crazy
we're gonna lock you in this magical
prison for all time because you're too
powerful to let you roam free
the way they explain that during the
shazam movie is that the seven deadly
sins themselves were the ones that
killed the other members of the council
of wizards
in the comics it was black adam that
killed the council they probably just
changed that to make him seem a little
less irredeemable because he's supposed
to be an anti-hero in this movie
so think of the end of the man of steel
movie where superman snapped zod's neck
more of that kind of action so superman
wasn't completely irredeemable but he
did wind up killing someone so obviously
that's going to be a little bit more
black adam's energy during the black
adam movie
number three a lot of you saw this
purple gem next to him in the trailer
when he talks about being imprisoned and
thought that it might be an eclipso
easter egg
you could think of it that way but it's
just meant to be the magical prison that
they trapped him in for thousands of
years
the gem that eclipso is trapped in is
called the heart of darkness it's also a
purple gem
so you can think of it as a reference to
that but i don't think they have big
plans for eclipso
in the black adam movie then he escapes
5000 years later in present day you can
see all the old monuments that he was
forced to help build have crumbled since
then
then he busts into the palace in this
scene and kills whoever this warlord is
that's controlling the area and takes
the throne from him
in the comics he eventually takes
control of kondok and rules over it with
an iron fist
so they're just saying that's what he's
going to be doing by the end of the
movie but then in present day as you see
him
cleaning out the trash in the area all
these different warlords and terrorists
he basically says the justice society
including hawkman and dr fake get
involved trying to stop him from killing
a bunch of people
so number two obvious question a lot of
you are asking where's the justice
league in all this why aren't they
helping out because this is supposed to
take place
after the events of the justice league
movie or the justice league snyder cut
however you want to think about it
my assumption is the reason the justice
society moves to stop him instead of the
justice league
is because hawkman would have some
previous knowledge of him from one of
his past lives
and dr fate would know all about him
because naboo is ancient and predates
black adam
so they both would have been around for
the period when he was first
unleashing the seven deadly sins and
just remembered that in present day
it sounds like when the movie picks up
in present day though per the trailer
the justice society
as it existed previously had been
fractured and they pick up adam smasher
and cyclone along the way to rebuild a
new version of the team
they'll probably explain what happened
to the original justice society and why
we're only hearing about them now
i think a lot of that continuity they'll
fix with the flash flashpoint movie
that's part of the idea too
is it sort of weaving in the other new
characters like shazam and black adam
just a couple of days ago the rock
confirmed that they'd cast aldis hodge
as their hawkman he also said that they
did have a hawk girl in the movie at one
point but had to take her out
when people asked him what happened to
hawk the rock said ah that's a story for
another time
so hopefully he'll spill the tea on what
happened to hot girl but it sounds like
per this trailer footage they team up
with black adam to defeat an even worse
villain in the area
they haven't confirmed who that's going
to be yet maybe felix faust or some
other big magic based villain it just
has to be somebody who's more terrible
than black adam to make him seem like
more of an anti-hero
then obviously number one wtf black adam
versus the justice league
the rock directly calls out all the
members of the justice league in that
trailer
superman in particular but i think
that's him implying that henry cavill
will cameo during the black adam movie
at some point
the rock has been teasing black adam
versus superman for a long time now but
it sounds like most of the movie is just
a society crossover with black adam not
justice league that's going to be for a
future movie
because zachary levi did say that when
they introduced his character in the
shazam movie
the idea was that he would join the next
version of the justice league when they
do eventually
make a justice league movie so i think
that just confirms that eventually they
will do black adam versus the justice
league down the road
but let me know in the comments what do
you think about the black adam movie so
far what are you most hyped up about i
know everybody just wants to see him go
off against all the different members of
the justice league
especially after we're getting the
justice league snyder cut there's going
to be a ton
of justice league stuff happening next
year it'll be crazy
really great justice league parody the
boys is actually airing episodes right
now episode 7 is gonna be dropping this
friday i'm doing videos for it as long
as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see those videos when i post it
but everyone click here to learn about
the brand new justice league snyder cut
scenes that zack snyder is going to be
filming with batman and ben affleck
and click here for the boys season 2
episode 6 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
you